[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAY JUDKOWITZ: Hello, everyone.
Thank you so much
for joining us today.
Very happy to
share with you what
we've been working on with
SRE practices, Stackdriver,
and the Istio Service Smash.
My name is Jay Judkowitz.
I'm one of the lead PMs
in Stackdriver at Google.
My co-presenter, Tim
Kelton, is co-founder,
head of SRE,
operations, and security
at Descartes Lab,
a customer of us.
And so we're going to learn
a little bit about what we're
doing in the product,
and then see what
Tim's doing over at Descartes.
So the purpose of
everything here
is to help people
adopt SRE practice
and to have the same kind
of efficiency operationally
as we have at Google.
And so we're not
going be able to do
the presentation
without starting
with a quick overview of SRE.
Then we're going
to dive into Istio.
Istio a really
important ingredient
for tying together
the SRE practice
and the Stackdriver
toolset, as we'll find.
Tim will come up and
talk about what Descartes
found in real life, trying
to manage their application
at scale, and how these
technologies are going
to come together to help them.
We'll talk about the Stackdriver
integration with Istio
specifically, and then
we'll get into a demo.
Who here was at the keynote this
morning at [INAUDIBLE] demo?
So we're going to see
that, but in more detail,
and on Tim's stuff
instead of Google's stuff.
So brief overview of SRE.
Google has eight products with
over a billion users on them.
We manage that with an
SRE team of 2,500 people.
Not that it works
this way, but that's
over 400,000 users
per operator, which
is pretty crazy economy
of scale and ability
to get the most out of folks.
Now, the challenge
that the SREs have
is, how do I keep
everything super reliable?
Of course, google.com
is synonymous with,
is my internet up?
But at the same time, Google has
its reputation for innovation.
There's a zillion developers
writing all these applications,
doing experiments, pushing
things out, pushing
the envelope.
How do you balance the
need for availability,
and reliability, and
performance with the need
for moving the business
forward and innovation?
That's what the SREs are about.
So what have we found
are the ingredients?
Now, this isn't an SRE talk.
The SREs would do a
full hour on this.
So I apologize to anybody
watching on YouTube later.
This is going to be a
very brief overview.
And this is the observations
we found from the Stackdriver
tooling side.
When we observe SREs, what do
we see makes things special?
First off is a culture.
SREs aren't just running
around with a pager
trying to squash bugs
and react to problems.
It's a very proactive
organization.
They engineer their
reliability into the products.
So pretty much all
the work they do,
it's frontloaded way before
you ever have an incident.
They're automating processes
for monitoring and automated
remediation so that things
hopefully don't get to a page.
They're doing production
readiness reviews
with the application teams.
Applications can't
go into massive scale
and SRE take the
pager unless they're
engineered for liability.
They're setting the principles
of monitoring and alerting.
They're managing the
customer promises,
whether they're internal
or external, the SLOs,
which you'd think I'm going
to talk about right now,
but we're going to push that
off a little bit later until we
talk about the SLO
feature, but that's
the most important thing.
And then, of course, they do
manage the incident response.
When there is an incident,
very scalable, flexible,
and predictable
process called IMAG,
which you can learn
more about in the book.
And they're responsible for the
blameless post-mortem culture
that we have, which
is really important.
You can't make things
continuously better
if people aren't comfortable
saying what's gone on,
saying what went wrong if
they're afraid of retribution.
So that's a brief overview
of the SRE culture.
Now, for that culture
to work, they need data.
Everything the SREs
do is data-driven.
Is it working well?
Is it reliable?
Is it cost-effective?
Is it going to scale?
Without the data, nothing works.
So the SREs, like I said, we've
got great economy of scale
on that team.
They're outnumbered over
10 to 1 by the developers.
Imagine the SREs went to every
development team and said,
I want you to put this
metric in this metric
in this metric in this metric,
and put it here, here, here,
here, and here.
Short conversation, right?
It's not going to go very well.
So what we've done at Google
is we've actually engineered
the SRE practices from
telemetry, at the least,
into the platform itself.
So when a Google engineer
on an application
deploys application code, it's
not just a container or a VM.
It is a service.
It's got a beginning and an end.
It's identifiable.
Schedulable as a unit.
It's got a discoverable
API with a known contract.
And it's got security and quota
management already available
to it.
And it's got the telemetry,
standardized telemetry,
so that anything
about that service
is sent back to the
monitoring systems.
So this is pretty cool.
So this allows SREs and
the software engineers
to actually be much
more collaborative,
because we're not pushing
work on one another.
We put the work on
the platform, you
deploy the code,
everything works.
Now, there's a little bit
of oversimplification.
I'm sure Google engineers would
say it's not always that easy.
But it's a pretty
good approximation.
So now what we've
done is, well, you all
can all develop on Google.
Or you don't work
at Google, but we
try to externalize the concepts
that we have into products
in the open-source.
So our container
scheduler, Borg,
is available as
Kubernetes, the concepts.
We're going talk about Istio.
That is basically inspired
by one platform, our API
management system.
Our secure RPC system
is externalized as gRPC.
And our instrumentation,
the things
that actually send the
metrics, traces, and whatnot,
it's something called census
internally [INAUDIBLE]
externalized as open census.
So not only have
we tried to make
this available for folks to
use on Google, but because it's
open-source, we let you
use it on competing clouds,
let you use it on-prem as well.
So hybrid multi-cloud version of
this opinionated infrastructure
that will make it
super easy for you
to manage applications as
a collection of services,
rather than a bunch of
infrastructure willy-nilly.
We're not going to talk
about this much at all,
but as you can imagine, with
all those engineers writing
all that code, sending all
those standardized metrics,
we got to put it somewhere.
So we have systems
inside Google that--
we get petabytes of logs a day.
We have billions of
monitored resources, hundreds
of billions of times series.
And this same system
is actually the basis.
It's the bottom half of
Stackdriver, the part
of Stackdriver you don't see.
So when you use
Stackdriver, you're
actually storing your
metrics or traces
in the same kind of system that
Google is storing their own.
Lastly, what this presentation
is really about is the tools.
We want to have this
culture change, deal
with monitoring by
SLO and working off
of this standardized platform
with these standardized
signals.
Well, to make that
all happen, you
have to have tools to
bring it all together.
There has to be great
UI and workflows that
let you see what you've
got, and be able to use it.
And that's the tip
of the iceberg.
You always see the iceberg,
and the thing on top
is what you see.
So those first three columns,
there's a lot of work in there,
and we're going to describe
the tip of the iceberg
and show you the tools
that we're building.
So with that, we want
to drill down on Istio.
Just show of hands.
Who here has heard
of Istio before?
Fantastic.
I guess that's why
you're in the room.
Who here has used it before?
Oh, wow, this is great.
So I will do a brief
treatment of Istio,
because again, this
is not an Istio talk.
But I do encourage people to go
to the Istio sessions as well.
So when people start breaking
up monolithic applications
into smaller and smaller
microservice applications,
the prototypical
two-pizza-box team,
you started creating a
lot more communication
between a lot more
pieces of software.
And that creates
a lot of problems.
If you had one monolithic
piece of software,
you'd put the security,
and the quota management,
and the instrumentation,
you'd just put inside monolith
and be done with it.
But now, if I've got tens or
hundreds of microservices,
I don't want to do that
again, and again, and again,
and again.
I just want to do that
once and be done with it.
And that's what Istio provides.
It provides security for
microservice communication.
So as the security becomes
configuration rather than baked
into the code, it provides
operational agility.
So you could say, hey, I want
to have this traffic splitting,
10% go here and 90% go here.
I want to do the canary.
I want to do the rollback.
I want to manage how
the traffic flows.
Again, that comes from Istio.
And lastly, the
uniform observability.
Because Istio is in this
place, this service mesh that's
available to all
services, the mesh
itself collects the
metrics and traces,
and sends everything to the
monitoring system of choice.
So this service
mesh is what creates
this open system for being
able to deploy code as services
and manage it through config,
rather than more and more
and more software logic.
In terms of the architecture--
so the key thing here
is the Envoy proxy.
The Envoy proxy is
what's sitting in
between service and service.
And its where the
metrics for the API
are captured and
enabled to be sent off.
The proxy is also
able to call out
to the mixer for things like
quota checks and security
checks.
And the mixer then doubles
also as an aggregation point.
So instead of having
to have a zillion
streams coming back to
your monitoring system,
being able to batch those up and
send it back in a sensible way.
Lastly, you have Pilot that is
pushing out the configuration
everywhere so that we can have
as many stateless pieces as
possible.
And Citadel, which is dealing
with the identity and security
pieces.
So that is a brief overview of
SRE, brief overview of Istio.
Very theoretical to this point.
So let's see practically,
how does Tim use
this to make Descartes better.
TIM KELTON: Thanks, Jay.
[APPLAUSE]
So just as Istio is focused
on providing visibility
into your services, and what
is happening between them
and how they interact,
Descartes Labs
is actually focused on improving
visibility and understanding
of changes that happen every
day all over the earth, all
over the globe, and how those
changes then might impact
our customers, their businesses,
and even their global supply
chains.
And we accomplish this through
building of machine learning
models.
And those are fused together
with many different types
of geospatial and
remote sensing data,
such as satellite imagery
or aerial imagery.
So you can think of that almost
as somewhat of a service level
indicator of monitoring
changes all over the earth.
And we're a startup that's
actually just a few years old.
Our headquarters are up in Santa
Fe, New Mexico, way high up
in the mountains.
And we don't actually
have any data centers.
We don't have any
physical servers.
So the cloud has been this
critical component for us
as far as infrastructure.
We could have never built
something on our own
this quickly as just a
couple-year-old startup.
And we have nearly 15
petabytes of satellite imagery.
And our machine
learning team needs
to scale models over
tens of thousands
of cores on any given day.
So whenever possible, we really
push to use managed services.
We're heavy users of GKE.
We also use Stackdriver for a
lot of our monitoring, logging,
tracing, all of those
types of things.
So how do we build these
service level indicators
for the whole earth?
Well, we do this by building
machine learning models,
like I said, and pulling
together this imagery.
But it's also not just about
having a single source of data.
Most of the time, the
accuracy in our models
comes about from
combining geographic data
across large geographies,
often through many different
spectrums of light,
not just human visible,
things like infrared, near IR.
Sometimes we'll
use remote sensing,
such as synthetic aperture
radar, or signals like that.
And then it's also
large temporal windows.
It's not just hours or
days, but sometimes we're
actually spanning, and building
models, and testing them back
over decades.
And no one data set usually
will just be the answer.
So in some ways,
this really isn't
that different than
understanding what's going on
with your microservice.
It's often the fusion of data
for many different services,
many different sources
together that give you
a full picture of how the
application is actually
interacting.
And so Descartes Labs model's
pull together internal data.
We pull in public data,
lots of imagery from NASA,
or Landsat, also the
European Space Agency.
But we also pull in many
commercial data sets.
We have a lot of our own data.
But we try and pair
the data with what
will provide the biggest
answers to provide context.
And our goal is to scale
up building of models
over massive geographic regions,
over many different modalities,
and over really large
temporal windows
to provide that insight
for our customers.
Some examples would
be just last Friday,
we were running models
and looking at building--
looking at hurricanes, and
Florida, and things like that.
And we were able to quickly
scale out, and build models,
and identify every single
building in the whole state
of Florida in just a few hours.
So what does our
architecture look like?
Well, we're very GKE-centric
on our microservices.
We have around 50 microservices.
We have, as I said, around 15
petabytes of earth observation
and sensor data.
Most of that is
actually stored in GCS.
We have some core
key services that
can selectively pull just
parts of the objects from GCS.
It could just pull, for
example, a single band of light,
and just be able to query that.
And we have to be able to scale
those compute jobs individually
to tens of thousands of cores.
And our microservices,
we have we
use a wide range of
data persistence tools,
besides just the object
store that's on GCS.
We impair the microservice
with the appropriate backend.
It could be Cloud
SQL, or big table,
or any of those databases.
And we leverage a lot of
them for each service.
But all of our monitoring,
logging, and tracing
is then back into Stackdriver.
So what are some of
the challenges we face
with scaling microservices?
Probably like
everyone here who's
had a lot of different services,
one of the biggest things
is visibility.
Understanding of
the source code,
the components,
what was deployed
with each of the microservices,
how each of those microservices
then start to interact together.
How many times does
a black box tester
maybe use one intended use case,
but then this microservice is
really valuable, and somebody
else finds out about it,
another developer starts using
it in a totally different way
that you never intended?
And so in my application
changes, another problem,
how do I quickly
observe what's going on?
We'll have applications
that are configured
with a variable maybe
was changed downstream,
and there was a
huge consequence.
It didn't show up
in early tests.
Maybe it changed the traffic.
Maybe the service to service
interaction is now different.
So if I release a
new version of code,
how do I gain
understanding about
did this improve my efficiency
on the backend of the service?
So what's really needed?
Prior to ever writing a
service level agreement
for any of our
customers, we really
have to understand the
performance baselines,
and the behaviors of
the actual application,
and how it's performing in real
world with real load traffic.
So what matters
or is notable, it
might not make any
difference to the customer.
We might have build
metrics and dashboards,
but the end customer actually
can't see the difference.
It could have problems still.
How do all the components of
the service then work together.
How can I easily track
how many errors are
acceptable for our customers?
When do we need to take a
step back on our development
roadmap, and look at instead
of maybe building new features,
we need to improve
the core stability?
What does the product
manager have to figure out
those types of priorities?
So overall, in some ways,
than when we move to Istio,
this really isn't
super different.
And this is awesome.
I am not putting
instrumentation libraries
into every single microservice
that we have out there.
There is that approach
and I could do that,
but we have services
written in a number
of different languages.
And I'm guessing many
of you do as well.
And so with Istio, as
Jay mentioned earlier,
one of the keys is
the Envoy proxy.
And we inject the sidecar
proxy in with the microservice,
and that gets deployed, and
you can actually set that up
to happen automatically.
So when those pods get deployed,
the Envoy sidecar proxy
gets reported in,
and then that metric
starts going into the backend.
So this starts to give
us instant visibility
into each service,
which services are
calling that specific service.
It gives us service-to-service
authorization.
We can do things like we might
need to rate limit a service.
For example, I like to use
auth as a really good example.
It's OK if it gets hit five
times a second from one
pod to another pod, but if
it starts getting hit 20, 30,
40,000 times a second
from pod, there's
probably something fishy that
was going on in that code.
And I would want
to go check that.
And overall, now
all of our services
are talking back into the
backend Istio control plane
with the pilot in the mixer,
as Jay was mentioning.
And then we have
Envoy just injected
into each of those containers.
And so with that--
JAY JUDKOWITZ: Thanks, Tim.
Thanks so much.
So we're going to talk a
little bit about the product
that we built, what we've
done to Stackdriver to be
able to better monitor Istio
with all that data we had.
I won't go into gory, gory
detail, because we're just
going to show you with Tim.
Next he's going to
come up and show you
what Descartes looks like.
But there's three problems
we really wanted to solve.
First problem is, what
the heck am I running?
What is my service architecture?
I could look at it from
a code perspective.
I can look at GitHub and see
all the different source files,
and maybe look at a build system
and see what the artifacts are.
But that doesn't
tell me anything
about the infrastructure.
I can look at the
infrastructure,
and look at VMs, and
pods, and containers,
and that tells me
what I'm consuming,
but it doesn't tell
me what I'm running.
What I really want is--
how many of you have
had to train a new hire?
What's the first thing you do?
You got to go to the whiteboard.
You go to the whiteboard
and you draw a picture.
You say, all right, we
have this thing here,
which does this function
and talks to that thing
there, which talks to that
function, which depends
on this thing over here.
And it turns out humans
have an incredibly intuitive
understanding of what
makes up a complex system.
And what we wanted to do
was be able to make it
so you'd have to draw
that on the whiteboard,
but instead got
that automatically.
And that's what the
service graph is about.
If we had a build up from
random pods and containers,
not so easy.
But because Istio is
opinionated about where
service starts
and ends, and it's
able to track which services
are talking to which
other services, it's actually--
I'm not going to say easy--
but it's certainly a lot
simpler to build this graph.
And that's what we've
done is basically
graphed out the entire
Istio service topology.
Now, we've done a couple other
things here that are important.
One is we've added
a time element.
So how many have you ever had
to do tech support for somebody
you love or care about?
What's your first question?
What did you change?
And what is their first answer?
Nothing.
And are they ever
telling the truth?
No.
[LAUGHTER]
So on the bottom there
is a time slider.
And so that time slider
lets you go back in time.
And so you can go see, OK,
what did the service look
like an hour ago?
What did it look
like two hours ago?
See where the changes come in.
Also, this doesn't replace
all of your dashboards
and everything, but you have
basic metrics for each service.
I mean, where are
the golden signals?
What do people care about?
What is my traffic?
What are my error rates?
What are my latencies
of various percentiles?
You get that at a glance.
And that's really,
really important,
because let's say you get a
support call about something
at the top of the tree.
Do you want to go debugging
that thing right away?
Maybe, but maybe not.
Maybe it's actually the thing
it depends on has problems.
So if you say, high
latency on something
up top, and then you look
at its five dependencies,
and you go, oh, wow,
one of those five
actually has high latency
down at the bottom.
I bet the high latency at the
top is caused by this one thing
down lower.
Then you can go debugging right
at the source of the problem.
So this is an
excellent triage tool,
because it gives you
an at-a-glance view
of all this stuff.
And then lastly, it
lets you drill down.
It doesn't end at
just a service list.
Actually, you can
double click on these
and go down from the workload
level to the deployment,
to the replica set, to
the pod, to the container,
and actually see if it
is an infrastructure
problem, which pieces
of infrastructure
you're going to want to look at.
Problem number two, how
is my service behaving?
Well, again, there's a lot
of different fractured points
of views of this.
You could look at
dashboards, which
show you a lot of
different metrics
about the infrastructure, or
response rates, or something
like that.
And that will give you one idea.
Or you can dive deep, deep,
deep into the code itself
and go, OK, what does a
distributed trace look like?
How is my latency distributed
between different microservices
that make up the app?
But again, you're not getting
a big picture view of it.
Where do you start with?
How do you build your
conceptual model?
And this is where we're
actually going off to the--
I promised I'd defer the
SLO conversation to here.
What you really want, or at
least what we want Google,
is service level objectives
for each service.
So think about how many
servers and how many containers
are running at Google.
Imagine if every time a CPU
went not, an SRE got paged.
That would never work.
That would never scale.
No 400,000 users per
SRE at that model.
So they automate a lot.
They automate the auto scaling.
So OK, the CPUs go
hot, you auto scale.
CPUs go down, everything's fine.
Nobody gets paged.
But you can only
automate so much.
You automate first thing,
and the next thing,
and the next thing.
And at some point,
you get to something
that didn't get automated
away, and the customer
experiences pain.
That's what we want to measure.
We want to learn, when does
the customer have pain, alert
on that, and do something.
So the first question is, what
is a service level indicator?
What is the thing the customer
notices and cares about?
There could be 100
answers to that question,
but there's two that come up
again and again, particularly
for API-based services.
One is availability.
What percentage of my
responses come back with 200s?
The second thing,
latency, performance.
Let's say a customer needs
300 milliseconds response
time on an API.
OK, what percentage
of API calls come back
with 300 milliseconds or less?
Those are your service
level indicators.
A service level objective is
when you put a target on that,
when you say, I want 99%
200 responses a week,
or I want 99.5% 300 milliseconds
or less response time.
The service level objectives
are now the promises
that we're making to
ourselves about our service.
It may be communicated
externally.
It's often not.
But it's important, because
without those objectives,
really hard to figure
out whether you're
doing well or not.
Now, you notice,
I didn't say 100%.
If I wanted 100% reliability,
we'd never release anything.
So when you take 100%
minus the target,
that's your error budget.
Your error budget says, how much
slack do I have this period?
So if your error budget
is really super high,
you're not spending it.
What happens when your
boss gives you money budget
and you don't spend it
by the end of the year?
Do you get that money
again the next year?
No.
They take it away.
So budget is there to be spent.
And so if your error budget is
super high all the time, well,
maybe it's time to
release more code.
Maybe it's time to
do more experiments.
Maybe it's time to see if
you can get more features out
to your customers,
because if it's
more reliable than
your customer's need,
they prefer features.
What if the error budget
is really, really low?
Well, you may want to hold
off on that big release.
And what if your error
budget is still within limits
but dropping precipitously?
Wake somebody up,
because otherwise, you're
going to be below and you're
not going to be happy.
So the error budget is really
how the SREs live and die,
and how they
organize their lives,
and how they know what they
should and shouldn't do.
You have a contract with
your internal and external
consumers.
You measure it, and
you work based on what
those measurements show.
And then of course,
you get a report.
At the end, you
can say, OK, did I
meet this SLO for this period?
Now, these SLOs are
pictures from Stackdriver.
So one of the
features that we've
got-- so the first feature
was the service graph
that we showed you.
Second feature is
this SLO feature.
So both for App Engine,
which isn't really
a part of this talk,
and Istio, we're
making it super easy
to put service level
objectives on your services,
measure them, and get
the graphs automatically, and
then be able to set alerts,
and know when to page
people based on those SLOs.
Problem number three, debugging.
So who here's used
Stackdriver before?
All right.
If this was a small room,
I'd ask how many parts
you can name.
There's metrics, and logging,
and traces, and profiler,
and debugger, and dashboards,
and error logging.
I'm probably skipping a couple.
It's a pretty broad
product, and they each
have their own screen.
So I can go to a metric screen.
I can go to a log screen.
I can go to a trace screen.
But if I'm debugging a problem
in a particular service,
I just want to know
everything about that service.
Don't show me all
the other stuff.
Show me everything
I care about about
the service in one place scoped
to the time of the problem.
And that's what we've built
with the service dashboard.
So the service
dashboard has a number
of elements, which
you're going to see
in Tim's demo in a second.
It's got a timeline
slider up above, which
shows all the relevant events.
You can open and
close the time slider
to get around the events
you care about and around
the time you care about.
And that filters everything else
that we're going to talk about.
There's events on the
side that give you
more details about
what's been going on.
And then there's these tabs.
And so the first tab is SLO tab.
Pretty important, because
when you're debugging,
you always start from
the broad and go deep.
So the broad thing is, oh, my
SLO's error budget is dropping.
OK, that's the broadest.
All right, what's the
next level of depth?
Metrics.
So for any given
service, we could say,
here's what the
transaction rate is.
Here's what the latency
distributions are.
And then we let you
slice and dice that.
So oftentimes, a service
doesn't just flat out die.
What usually happens
with a service is,
some subset of
traffic is broken.
This version, from this
sender, in this location.
You want to be able to
slice and dice the traffic,
and figure out
who's the outlier.
Who's the subset
of traffic that's
making the overall thing bad?
And so the service level metrics
about availability and latency
let you do that.
Now, once you've figured
out what subset of traffic
you care about, you can
dig into diagnostics.
Let's look at traces.
Let's see what the different
percentiles of traces are.
Let's go into that.
Maybe it's not a performance.
Maybe it's an
availability thing.
So we want to look
at error reports
and see what kind of
stack traces we've got.
And then there's everybody's
favorite, the least common
denominator of debugging, logs.
When all else fails,
read the log files.
So with this, we're
able to go, again,
from the big picture
of the service graph,
say, hey, which service
is likely at fault, down
into that service's
dashboard, find the SLO,
to the service metrics, down
to the individual diagnostic
pieces.
Ultimately, we'll also want to
include debugger and profiler,
and launch off into there.
But you can imagine how
that would add on later.
So who wants to see Tim show
you the product instead of me
talking and doing screenshots?
Yeah?
All right.
[APPLAUSE]
So please switch computers.
TIM KELTON: All right,
so I am coming in.
I'm brand new.
I'm a new SRE.
Like Jay said, we could
whiteboard this all out.
But now my services are actually
injected with the Envoy sidecar
proxy.
They're all reporting up
into the Istio control plane.
And I can start going in
and exploring what does
my service actually look like.
I can start trying
to understand,
are any other services
calling our service?
So like I said earlier,
we serve lots and lots
of pixels or imagery.
It's also known as Rasters.
So we have a service
called Raster.
And this service,
just as a background,
this is a Python Flask
application that's
hitting GCS on the backend.
And I can see, actually,
it looks like I
have two types of traffic.
I have data going to
the metadata service,
and then it looks like I
have some client requests
from black box.
So I actually
didn't know, no one
told me in the
documentation anything
about this metadata service.
I'm just trying to learn.
So I'm going to actually go
look up what is the metadata.
Well, in our case, metadata is
information about each scene.
Which bands of light, which
time was this image taken, maybe
which sensor was it.
Was it from NASA or something?
That would be the
types of information
that we would store in metadata.
And then this example, we
have the backend of metadata.
We've made an index to be
able to look things up.
And as Jay mentioned, you can
start to see a high level.
I can see some request counts.
I can actually also see here--
I don't see any traffic
here, but oh, this
is non-200 responses.
So that's actually good that
I'm not seeing anything.
And I can also see response
latencies, and dive
down into what are my
long tail events there.
But this is just a
high level overview.
Then one thing to point
out, because this is just
the open-source
elastic search server.
So that's open-source
code that I'm not
adding any sort of
libraries or metrics to.
Instead, I'm just sitting
behind the Envoy proxy.
So now I know that
our SRE team wants
to throw requested traffic
that we know about.
So we made this
black box tester.
And that actually uses
our Python client,
and it calls out
to these services.
It looks like it's now calling
to metadata and Raster.
I can see that from
the traffic side.
And so that's the use case that
I've seen at this given time.
So now I'm going to go look
at an SLO that I've made.
This was over a week.
And I'm looking at the SLO
for our Raster service.
Or I'm sorry, this
is over the last day.
And I'm looking at
all the tail events.
I can start to see that, oh,
it's actually hovering right
around that service level
indicator, that threshold
that we set.
It's 99.5% of that indicator.
And now I'm looking
at the error budget.
And it looks like we were
actually really good until
late last night.
And then it looks like latency
started just dropping off,
and our error budget is
actually starting to go down.
And actually I'm
starting to see now
that it looks like it's
actually declining more.
I can also dive into some of
the events that happened earlier
today.
It looks like there was an
event around just before noon.
I can see that we
had some incidents.
But now I want to actually
zoom in and say, actually,
what's going on right now?
And it looks like my service
has actually dropped quite a bit
below.
And I actually have a
big problem right now.
I need to figure
out what's going on,
and I need to basically stop
the bleeding to some extent.
I'm seeing latencies
dropping well
below what we were hoping for.
I'm seeing we're
burning error budget.
I'm seeing our service
is out of compliance.
Basically, it's all hands
on deck at this point.
So what I'm going to
do on the backend,
I've seen that Raster is where
all those core requests are
coming in.
So I actually am going to--
probably we didn't set
our HPAs correctly.
Maybe we're not scaling
on the right metrics.
Maybe we need something
more specific.
But I'm going to scale this
up, and just try and get
the service back in compliance.
And so while these pods
are all initialising--
I'm making a whole
bunch right now--
while these pods
are initialising,
as was mentioned earlier,
I can start diving deeper
into the problem.
I want to get a
better understanding
of what are actually the
metrics that we're seeing.
And so one thing I can
do is I can actually,
because I know which
service is talking to which
other-- or Istio knows.
Sorry, I don't actually
know at this point.
But I can actually
group by something
like the source workload name.
Another thing I could
do is I could actually
look at response code.
I could say, just show
me the 200s, for example,
if I knew all my traffic.
But I actually know
there's a problem.
So I want to see,
are all the workloads
hitting this API, the
things I know about,
or is there actually
something new coming in?
And then I can scroll
down and I can actually
see that there's a new
service that's hitting.
Some developer got the wild idea
that he knew how to use my API
and he was going to
make this killer app.
And he is basically
crushing that single pod.
So that was never
going to scale,
and my latencies were going
to basically drop off.
And I can start seeing the
here that the latencies
are getting slower and slower.
So now I've added more
backend Raster pods.
I should be able to
start handling that load.
And now I might want to go
in and dive even deeper.
The next step I would
do is I would actually
want to look at the
diagnostics themselves.
So these are some
of the requests,
and the percentile,
and the latency.
And I can actually
see a sampling
of what some of those
calls to Raster were.
I can actually start
going in and seeing,
here's this Raster service.
And I'm seeing
these slower times.
These were in the 90
and 95th percentile.
And I can actually start
seeing the full traces.
One thing to mention,
we've actually--
I can click around
on a few of those.
I can look down at
that time window,
and I can actually see
some of the logs coming in.
And I can look at--
we're having some
problems, it looks like.
I can see logs relative
to this small time window
just to this service.
It's already filtered
that down for me.
I didn't actually build any of
these dashboards or widgets.
So that's really helpful.
Here I actually see
some good requests.
I can actually see we
served Raster imagery.
Looks like this was a metadata
request to NASA Landsat scene.
So that's really nice to be
able to compartmentalize that.
Oh, and look, I just now am
seeing an incident pop up.
I am seeing I actually
have an error budget.
I'm losing error budget, and
I now have a new incident.
So I might want to start
understanding that.
So now at this point, hopefully
we've stopped the bleeding.
So at this point,
I thought it would
be helpful to just
show actually how
I make an SLO to begin with.
Since all of my services
are behind Istio,
I can actually use the service
graph or the service explorer,
and I can actually see all
of those services themselves.
And so I can actually
go find the--
which service was this?
OK, I am in the Roswell
Kubernetes project.
I'm picking good
New Mexican names.
That's a city in New Mexico,
if you're not familiar.
And I can go look for--
let's see.
Where is Roswell?
Oh, sorry.
Oh, I've already selected that.
I've self-selected.
But these were all
populated from Istio.
So now that I've populated
that Raster service,
I can actually add an SLO.
And I can do an SLO
with two different types
of service level indicators.
One would be availability.
Maybe my application
always has to be up.
That's what's most critical
for our line of business.
In this case, I just
showed you, we're
serving all these
varying size imagery.
And really what crushes us from
day to day maybe is latency,
and how quickly
or how responsive
that service actually is.
So in this case,
what I'm going to do
is I'm going to make this
service respond with 4,000
milliseconds, or four seconds.
And then I can pick a period.
In real life, I
would usually often
use maybe a month
or at least a week.
In this case, we're
building a demo,
and I'm just walking
through how we build these.
So I'm going to actually
select just one day.
And then finally, I can
pick a target compliance.
What's the percentage of
traffic that should be served?
When the latency falls
lower than this amount,
it starts being a really bad
experience for our customers,
and we want to do
something about it.
So in this case,
I think I'm going
to try 99.5% of that latency.
And so remember, this
was just over a day.
So 99% of that traffic, if
I broke 99% up in minutes,
that's about 7 and
1/2 minutes of the day
that the latency can't be below.
So that's actually
probably pretty high.
It might be too aggressive.
I'm not sure.
I'm going to actually see.
Now, this is really nice,
because what's happened
is they've looked at
the traffic coming in
between those services.
And I didn't pre-populate
or pre-build this.
It's actually pulled
all the request latency.
And then I can see where I
fit on that 99.5% threshold.
Was that really the right
level to put on a service level
indicator?
Actually, I think that
that's not doing too bad.
I'm looking pretty good there.
And then I can see what my
error budget would have been.
And then I can finally see where
my compliance would have been.
And this was a demo cluster.
We've only been running
load for a couple of days,
so that's actually why this load
stops showing previously there.
So that's just a
walkthrough of how
you can get started building
SLOs once they're behind Istio.
So at this point, I think I'm
going to check on incidents,
and I'm going to see if
I have any incidents.
And look, I actually have
budget loss incident.
It's now been going
for seven minutes.
If I had set up Stackdriver
paging or alerting based
on that, that would have started
burning through the error
budget right there.
So at this point, what I'm going
to do is I'm going to go back
and I'm going to see if
adding all those Raster pods,
did that actually
help anything at all?
I'm going to expand
the service bar out.
And then I'm going
to look at what's
been happening with my SLO.
And I just want to zoom
in really, really close.
And it actually looks like
I'm starting to see latency
now begin to improve.
It reached a bottom, it looked
like it was getting around
98.15%.
But now finally, latency
is starting to get better.
I was burning error budget.
I'm hoping that that error
budget has now stabilized
and we're starting
to flatten out.
You can see I'm now
out of compliance.
So hopefully these changes will
start scaling more and more
pods.
And at this point,
we'll start going back
into full compliance.
And so at this point,
I think we've walked
through all the major areas.
JAY JUDKOWITZ: Thank
you so much, Tim.
[APPLAUSE]
All right, so, let's see.
I've got 2 and 1/2 minutes.
What can I tell you?
So just to recap, SRE
practices are awesome.
Istio is platform
technology that
helps you get there
so that you don't
have to build all
the SRE practices
into each microservice yourself.
Stackdriver automates the
creation of service graph,
automates the creation
of dashboards,
automates the graphing of SLOs.
Like Tim showed, you just
have to supply the target,
and it takes it from there.
Hopefully this gives you
the best possible visibility
into your services,
and also gives you
the best possible mean
time to resolution
when problems do occur.
I definitely
encourage you to see
some of the other talks
that are out there.
And we're in early
access for the software
that we showed you.
It's not generally released yet.
So if anybody wants
take a picture
of that link, the
shortened link,
that's the survey to
apply for the software
to get early access.
Yeah, so thank you very, very
much for your attendance.
Really appreciate everything.
And thank you, Tim,
for contributing.
You would not believe what this
guy went through last week.
So thank you, everyone, and
enjoy the rest of the show.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]